x-men the animated series dazzled 90s
viewers with action drama and real world
storytelling
so sophisticated is this cartoon in fact
that a whole lot of it goes over kids
heads
we're here to explore those details
aimed straight at x-men's older audience
disenfranchised people have long seen
themselves in the x-men
and the creators behind the animated
series knew how important it was to
respect that
as writer julia leewald told vulture fox
was very conscious of making the show
inclusive without
being intrusive about it the show's
interest in diversity extended beyond
the main cast
as well bishop a black mutant from the
future was one of the show's most
memorable guest characters
racism is also handled head on in the
episode one man's worth the team is
forced to deal with a racist who
confronts storm and wolverine when he
sees them holding hands
the series also doesn't shy away from
powerful women allowing rogue
storm jean grey and others to dazzle on
screen
this was accomplished in part by
deliberately hiring more female writers
forget it lady
scott's my date x-men is even relatively
progressive where gender identity is
concerned
consider the actions of shapeshifters
such as morph and mystique who often
change gender to flirt with the opposite
sex
it might seem smart to keep politics out
of a saturday morning cartoon but
there's no way to completely eliminate
the political nature of the x-men
one of the series main antagonist in the
first few episodes is senator
robert kelly who declares his intentions
to run for president
kelly is playing to his highly
xenophobic base which means that his
policies are heavily anti-mutant
later on professor x takes center stage
when he meets with politicians and even
goes to washington to speak on behalf of
mutants everywhere
russian politics come up in an episode
in which the russian x-man colossus's
past is explored and russian serial
killer omega red attempts to overthrow
the government
not even canada looks clean once
wolverine's past working for the
canadian government is covered in a
searing episode
x-men also explores intra-mutant
politics like those of the morlocks
a band of mutants who dwell underground
storm ultimately challenges callisto
their leader in an effort to save the
team her victory makes storm the
technical leader of the sewer dwellers
though she doesn't stick around to abuse
that power and later relinquishes it
back to callisto
superhero comics usually follow
individuals portrayed as being at peak
physical condition who are poured into
tight spandex
the x-men and many of their foes are no
exception and their cartoon gets
positively risque at times consider
rogue who is one of the more flirtatious
characters in the show
she deals with the fact that her mutant
power means that she can't touch
anyone by delivering flirty lines when
rogue first sees colossus she muses
now that is a shame locking up a big
good looking hunk of mutant like that
rogue's voice actress lenore zan has
said that creators were quote asking for
a sexy husky female voice with a
southern accent
clearly they got what they asked for
flirty interactions between unexpected
characters often make the most impact in
x-men
sabertooth asks wolverine if he wants to
kiss and make up while in the same
episode
rogue flirts with cyclops as she gives
him cpr it's better than not breathing
come on pretty boy make a girl feel
welcome
she follows this up once their powers
return to normal by telling cyclops that
they'll have to try it again sometime
things get even more overt when cyclops
is kidnapped by the morlocks for the
purpose of giving callisto an
air kids might not pick up on these sly
innuendos but adults definitely will
slavery infests some of the darkest
parts of human history and depicting it
especially in a saturday morning cartoon
can leave quite an impression
in a season one arc several members of
the x-men are sent to investigate the
tropical vacation spot
and mutant utopia known as genocia but
everything about the island is a lie the
heroes are soon captured and thrown into
cells with other mutants who are kept
alive and used as slave labor
each of them is forced to wear a collar
that dampens their powers
except when their powers are necessary
to do manual labor
it makes for brutal viewing especially
for a children's cartoon
other forms of extreme bigotry are
examined within the series
when exploring magneto's past the
holocaust is alluded to
mutants are rounded up and imprisoned
especially in episodes exploring the
future
senator kelly even talks about putting
them in internment camps before he is
saved by the x-men and turned into an
ally
mutants always seem one step away from
being banished segregated or losing all
of their rights
the x-men deal with hatred and
persecution constantly
it's a theme that is explored throughout
the majority of their comics and the
cartoon captures it excellently
mutants are hated hunted and attacked
their most active human enemies are soon
given a name
the friends of humanity it isn't hard to
see that this collective is meant to
mirror modern day neo-nazi groups down
to their symbolism rallies
and mob-like mentality the best example
of this comes in the episode beauty and
the beast
beast and a colleague have developed a
treatment to restore a young woman's
sight but her father
hates beast and wants him away from his
daughter it's an emotional story as
beast is in love with the young woman
who is later kidnapped by the hate group
it is also an episode in which the
audience hears the word bigot
as the show draws a direct parallel
between the plight of mutants and
persecuted groups in the real world
the aids epidemic was a major part of
the 80s and 90s
one which led to the stigmatization of
the gay community
in addition to being associated with
other marginalized groups the x-men are
often seen as a reflection of the gay
community as well
so it isn't a surprise that an arc about
a deadly virus sweeping through the
mutant community has drawn some
comparisons to aids
granted the legacy virus storyline
involves some outlandish superhero
storytelling
what with its time travel and the whole
plague being a plot by the villain
apocalypse
but there are still some poignant
moments and the comparison holds
much in the same way that victims of the
aids epidemic were treated with fear and
hostility by the mainstream rather than
the care
and compassion they deserved the
manufactured legacy virus is used to
frame mutants in a bad light and
generate more hatred toward them
anti-mutant bigots claim mutants infect
humans with the virus
braden creed leader of the foh
accidentally infects himself with it
before blaming his infection on the
mutant bishop
in the future that bishop is trying to
prevent many mutants are shown to be
locked up in quarantine out of societal
fear and
even more have died from the legacy
virus though the x-men do eventually
save the day the image of stigmatized
suffering mutants lingers
though the character spends the majority
of the first season in jail beast is
in fact lucky to be there since he was
almost not included in the show at all
george busa's performance and the
writer's passion for the character made
sure beast became a bigger part of
season 2.
audiences see beast's big brain at work
all the time and are regaled with his
many musings
philosophical answers and overly verbose
intellectual statements
younger viewers are most likely confused
by this blue haired genius as when in
one episode he discusses a teammate's
nom de guerre
adults however might get a good chuckle
out of beast's advanced vocabulary
beast is often seen reading especially
while in prison
it pays off he readily cites the works
of shakespeare
lord tennyson and john dunn though i am
always in haste
i am never in a hurry john wesley
in mere moments the file shall be no
more
beast isn't the only one who gets to
deploy references that most kids won't
grasp however
morph gets some stolen robert frost
lines in wolverine quotes dirty hairy
and the shining to terrifying effect
rogue makes an obscure golf reference
then there are the large number of
scientific terms used throughout the
series like when the team learns about
temporal displacement and darwinism
you certainly can't accuse x-men of
lacking in educational content
being a member of the x-men isn't easy
the fighting is constant and often leads
to death
viewers are exposed to this early on in
the first story arc when morph is
thought to have been killed
later on the dark phoenix storyline
deals a devastating blow to the x-men
with gene grey's apparent death
there is also the series finale which
sees the team deal with the loss of
charles xavier who narrowly avoids death
but becomes lost to his mutant family
perhaps forever
while the deaths in the show often end
up being more temporary than they first
seem the grief the characters feel at
the time is genuine
the show also explores several alternate
worlds that force viewers to confront
the deaths of beloved characters
the days of future past episodes follow
wolverine in the future condemned to
walk past the graves of
all his fallen friends another world
features a married wolverine and storm
who are recruited to help set time right
again
tragically doing this means that their
lives and their love are erased
the tears they shed when they realize
that they have succeeded are deeply sad
the most unique instance of loss on the
show comes when the mansion is destroyed
wolverine reminisces out loud about how
it is one of the few homes he's ever
known
seeing someone so stoic lament a
building is a moving moment
the x-men have a lot of baggage and
relationship drama is constant
classic love triangles abound most
prominently between cyclops jean grey
and
wolverine as well as unrequited love and
even divorce
several mutants are disowned by their
parents the proteus episodes revealed
that one of the world's most powerful
mutants in the world just wants
acceptance from his father
throw in several interrupted marriages
surprise announcements of parenthood and
a couple of shapeshifters and things get
crazy
morph pretending to be scott and jean's
priest to ensure their marriage's
illegitimacy is perhaps the peak of this
pettiness and drama
frankly x-men feels like a daytime soap
opera in many ways
but these ultra-emotional moments also
make the characters feel very
dare we say human the series writers
wanted to showcase the characters
battling their own inner demons as well
as their physical enemies
viewers are the winners here because
this exploration ultimately gives great
depth to the storytelling
plus as there isn't a lot of media for
kids that discuss
things like death divorce and how to
deal with strong emotions
x-men is downright helpful to little
ones seeking guidance the show knows
kids aren't stupid even if they don't
grasp
every single detail the way their
parents do incorporating so many
dramatic elements might make the show
soapy but
it also makes it important ain't that
enough
religion is very much a part of x-men
fictional religions exist
like those who worship garrok in the
savage lands
moreover storm herself is sometimes
referred to as a goddess
christianity is also present on the show
explored in episodes like descent
which discusses the evolution of mutants
and episodes featuring nightcrawler
whose catholicism is a big part of his
character
nightcrawler has an unsettling
appearance his blue skin
yellow eyes and prehensile tail give him
the appearance of a demon
he even smells of sulfur when using his
teleportation powers
it's no surprise then that a mob comes
to destroy nightcrawler insisting that
god is with them on their mission
an episode appropriately enough titled
nightcrawler explores having faith
losing it and renewing one's
relationship with the divine
it also discusses the question of why
god would create mutants in the first
place in an unexpected moment toward the
end
nightcrawler gives wolverine a bible
with several marked passages
the episode ends on a scene of wolverine
reading passages out loud in a church
this is particularly striking given
wolverine cynicism
but somehow against all odds
nightcrawler's kindness has reached him
nightcrawler speaks often about
forgiveness and compassion even for
those in his family who did horrible
things to him
he always tries to live by god's words
and x-men is
interested in exploring what that means
with the depth that adults are likely to
appreciate
x-men the animated series is full of
violence but as is the case with many
cartoons few of those kicks and punches
can actually do
any lasting damage or else things might
get bloody
how do you inject a sense of danger into
action scenes then
the inclusion of sentinels and other
robots as primary antagonists helps
tremendously with this dilemma
these giant menaces are a godsend for
simulated violence
as julia leewald remarked if action's
going to be
big it's going to involve sentinels
getting bits torn off and thrown about
you couldn't do that with living things
ripping cybernetic parts off of a human
as happens with donald pierce during the
fight with the hellfire club is
also allowed but skirts the line these
workarounds allow fans to see wolverine
and others decapitate dismember and
eviscerate their enemies using their
powers to their fullest extent
it's not just the physical cost of
violence that skirts a mature line
either many characters
also go out of their way to hurt
innocents or are obsessed with being
cruel
magneto swears revenge on quite a few
people
archangel dedicates his wealth to
tracking down and destroying apocalypse
in an episode blatantly titled obsession
violence is ingrained in the lies of
these characters and
in the show itself check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about x-men are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]